こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーです。
お前ら、
イライラしてないか？最近。
(ドン！)
俺は超イライラしてるぞ、今日。
(ドドドドド…)
なんかもう…
今すぐにでも
物を壊したい気分なので
今日は、
こちらにね、ちょっと、風船パックがあるんですけども、
もうすごい数の風船を準備しました。
この風船を、全部膨らまして
それをもう一個づつ割っていって
もうストレスを、
全部発散しようと思います！
(ドドン)
行くぞ！
はじめ：だれですか！？
ブレイブ：助けてください。
はじめ：え…
はじめ：MEGさん？…
MEGWIN：あれ？しゃちょー？
マッスル：道に迷ってしまって、、、たすけてください！
マッスル：化け物に追われてるんです！
はじめ：化け物？なに言ってるんですか。
スマート：ドアの外に
ブレイブ：駄目だ！
はじめ：きゃああああああああああああうああぁうあぁうぅ…
はじめ：なんなんですか？あれは！？
ブレイブ：隙間男っていう化け物です。
MEGWIN：このままじゃここで死ぬぞ。
はじめ：風船がある。
はじめ：思いつきました。
ブレイブ：え？
はじめ：風船でこの部屋をいっぱいにするんです。
はじめ：そしたら、
はじめ：隙間男が入ってきても、僕らがどこにいるか分かりません。
マッスル：で？
はじめ：みんなそっち側に隠れて、
はじめ：隙間男が入ってきた瞬間、みんな一斉にこの部屋から出ていくんです。
おぉ～
ブレイブ：やりましょう。
はじめ：いきます。
ブレイブ：はい。
はじめ：もう一体居たんだ。
はじめ：ぎゃああああああああ
はじめ(隙間男)：うわぁーーー
わぁぁあぁぁぁぁあぁぁぁ
わぁああああああああああ
スマート：わぁあああ
ブレイブ：ぅわあああああああ
マッスル：ぅわああああ
ブレイブ：違う選択肢を選べば、上手くいくかもしれない。
ブレイブ：風船…
ブレイブ：うまくいくとおもったんだけどなぁ…
ブレイブ：今すぐ選択し直そう
ブレイブ：時間がない！